be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
and so what I wanted to do here is have
a discussion about the difference
between the negative zone and the end
zone and Marvel Comics the reason for
this is that with a Fantastic Four film
pulling heavily from the ultimate
universe and because the ultimate
universe is a reimagining of various
characters and teams from the mainstream
Marvel Universe I feel like some
explanation is necessary regarding how
the negative zone and the end zone
relate to one another and how they
pertain to various adventures and
escapades of the Fantastic Four so the
best way to think of the negative zone
is that it exists as a parallel reality
to the mainstream Marvel Universe the
first appearing in Fantastic Four number
51 the negative zone was discovered
accidentally by Reed Richards while
muffled doesn't give us much in terms of
its initial discovery what we're told is
that following the attempt by Galactus
to consume the planet Earth and his
defeat by the combined efforts of Silver
Surfer and the Fantastic Four in issues
number 46 to 48 Reed rationalized that
because of the vast powers available to
Galactus as well as other threats that
may exist in the universe the heroes of
Earth were largely unprepared or
incapable of combating such a threat
then learn to ensure the safety of the
planet Reed wanted to have a way to send
these threats to another dimension
should they ever become a danger to
earth and all life with them to this end
Rhee developed a device that allowed
transdimensional travel and in his
efforts to discover alternate realities
stumbled upon the negative zone now in
terms of characteristics what Marvel
tells us is that the negative zone is
called this because all matter within is
negatively charged to clear the top of
it all objects including the molecules
that make up the negatives on itself are
composed of antimatter if a person or
object were to attempt to enter the
negative zone they would have to reverse
the polarity of their molecular
structure what this means is that with
all matter outside of the negative zone
composed of protons neutrons and
electrons an antimatter is composed of
the opposite which are anti protons
antineutrons and positrons without a
reversing polarity upon entrance the
antiprotons and antineutrons and paolo
Tron's that make up the negative zone
would cancel out the protons neutrons
and electrons
that make up normal matter than the
outrage a person would simply cease to
exist
now the reversing of an object or
person's molecular polarity happens
automatically when they pass through the
fabric of infinity or as it's sometimes
called the distortion zone once passed
this area they next enter the space
between realities while no name is given
to this area in Fantastic point number
51 when Reid entered this space he
described it as a four-dimensional
universe that he could only observe in
three dimensions this resulted in the
space around him appearing as
nonsensical shapes and eventually
massive stretches of light now assuming
a person is able to make it through all
of this what they would find in a
negative zone is a universe relatively
similar to our own but different at the
same time as it's explained in Fantastic
Four number 253 the negative zone is a
universe far older than the mainstream
mobile continuity and that is actually
approaching its own destruction in
Fantastic Four number 319 this was
expanded on what has revealed that while
the universe came into existence by way
of a Big Bang as time passed the
universe began to stop growing and
instead began to close it on itself
while the reason behind this is not
explicitly given to us I would argue
this is simply the result of the
gravitational pull of all objects within
the negative zone pulling towards one
another now within the center of the
negative zone is a massive black hole
and within the core this black hole is
what's referred to as the crossroads of
infinity like walking through a hallway
of doors if a person were to travel into
the black hole and withstand the extreme
tidal forces they could actually enter
other realities in the Marvel Universe
which points towards the fact that
there's only one negative zone and the
entire Marvel multiverse now in terms of
all the space outside of the black hole
most of this is simply uncharted however
over the course of various Fantastic
Four stories bubble provides us with
backstories on some of these races in
Fantastic Four issues of a 140 for
example we get a limited explanation on
a race called the taiana's presented as
a first race to come into existence in
the negative zone their evolution led
them to a point of technological
advancement where they began to look
towards the Stars but seeing it as our
destiny to spread their race across a
negative zone and see two other worlds
to evolve on their own the ship carrying
these scores was struck by an asteroid
and as a result
they crashed on a barren planet now out
of these fours grew an insectoid being
who would eventually become Annihilus
the famed enemy of the Fantastic Four -
an attempt subtle invasions of the
mainstream Marvel continuity but fail
each time after evolving and seeking out
the ship previously belonging to the
tie-in ins a nihilist found that the
race had actually gone extinct but using
their technology an eyeless was able to
develop an object called the cosmic
control rod while the rod has the power
to manipulate the energies of the
negative zone for virtually any province
Annihilus only really uses it the key to
the selfie yawning in an effort to stave
off death now in addition to the
evolution of a nihilist the actions of
the planets also gave us the balunians
while nothing truly known about this
race the only person ever encountered
that hails from these beings is a
villain named blast star it cast out by
his society black star first appeared in
Fantastic Four number 62 when Rita taken
a trip to the negative zone for the
purpose of mapping planets the following
Reed Richards back to the portal and
into the mainstream continuity blast
star was defeated by the Fantastic Four
and the Inhumans and sent back to the
negative zone now while other races like
the ark or the a throws the caster and
the Utah are listed as existing in the
negative zone my research hasn't
revealed any information that can verify
their existence and so I don't really
have any information to offer on these
races
now with a mainstream / universe has a
negative zone the ultimate universe
which the 2015 Fantastic Four film draws
from has the end zone the confusion that
exists for many more fulfill their
attempts to reconcile the concepts of
the end zone and the negative zone and
so while almost no information is given
to us you're going to the nature of the
end zone what we do know is that with
the ultimate universe being a
reimagining of many of Marvel's premiere
heroes and teams for modern leaders
under Brian Michael Bendis and Warren
Ellis Marvel took the concept of the
negative zone and recreated it
introduced in the end zone as a separate
universe from the negative zone the to
share very close similarities but they
also have distinct differences like the
negative zone the end zone is a universe
unto itself that is on the verge of
collapse it's presumed to contain
various alien races and can be accessed
by way of transdimensional travel
however unlike the negative zone the end
zone does not have a black hole at its
center that acts as an access point to
alternate realities and the very
molecules that make up the end zone have
a corrosive nature that eats away at
organic material with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will catch you guys later peace